bonjour à tous
nicolas sarkozy souhaitait simplifier le
mille-feuille territorial
mais le sénat ne lui a pas facilité la
tâche c'est avec une très courte
majorité que le sénat a finalement
adopté cette nuit est la réforme des
collectivités territoriales mais les
sénateurs ont détricoté le texte en
supprimant l es deux mesures phare
contre l'avis du gouvernement le sénat a
donc rétabli la clause de compétence
générale pour les communes les
départements et les régions
cette clause permet aux collectivités de
s'emparer de domaines qui ne sont pas
forcément de leur ressort
le gouvernement souhaitait la supprimer
pour les départements et les régions
autre mesure phare du texte rejeté par
les sénateurs le mode d'élection des
conseillers territoriaux
ces conseillers remplaceront les
conseillers généraux et régionaux à
partir de 2014 le gouvernement
souhaitait les voir élire au scrutin
uninominal à deux tours
mais les centristes ne l'entendait pas
de cette oreille ils exigeaient à
l'introduction d'une dose de
proportionnelle
leur vote a donc entraîné le rejet de
cet article majeur
le mode d'élection des conseillers
territoriaux sera donc examinée dans un
projet de loi ultérieur
c'est donc un texte profondément
remaniée qui a été voté par le sénat est
tout de suite direction l'hémicycle pour
suivre les débats et le vote qui ont
donc eu lieu est cette nuit mais à nous
reprenons notre travaux mes chers
collègues
le président de la commission si vous
voulez bien nous faire rapport les
travaux de la commission
oui oui merci monsieur le président la
commission a donc à examiner les trois
amendements déposés par le gouvernement
et le premier a et a donné un avis
favorable à cet amendement également sur
le à deux ils n'ont pas été présentés
c'est vrai monsieur le président et dont
le rapport à l'or et bien autres et sur
le troisième but et vous savez que nous
avions dit il faut mieux différé le la
question des cumuls parce qu'il nous
avait paru notamment pour les
intercommunalités 20000 était un peu bas
à partir du moment où ses 30000 ça nous
paraît beaucoup plus raisonnable en
disant d'ailleurs qu'il fallait faire
attention à ce que ça n'évite pas
d'effusion de co2 de communautés parce
que si on met le seuil trop bas et bien
les présidents vous pensez bien qui
fusionneront pas si en plus ils soient
assurés de perdre un mandat faut quand
même veiller à ça puisque quand même
l'objectif du premier tour du projet de
loi est quand même de favoriser une
carte des intercommunalités plus
cohérentes qu'elle n'est aujourd'hui
donc là aussi monsieur le président et
après les débats que nous avions eu la
commission des lois donné un avis
favorable
bien avant que je demande au
gouvernement de nous préciser si
l'amendement mais je collais souhaité
faire un bref rappel au règlement qui
naturellement ils sont sur la chaîne
française i dames messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
un bref rappel au règlement pour revenir
je vous promets très brièvement sur le
scrutin 258 et notamment sur le vote sur
l'amendement 580 pour dire
qu'effectivement nous avons constaté
après avoir pris connaissance des
résultats que nous avions commis une
erreur matérielle dans les consignes de
vote qui nous était donné je voulais
simplement le préciser
dont acte merci à monsieur le président
alors monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre michel mercier
l'amendement à un oui merci monsieur le
président l'amendement à 1 du
gouvernement a pour objet de supprimer l
article 1er aaa en cohérence avec les
dispositions qui ont été prises par le
sénat en supprimant l'article 35
très bien alors explications de vote
monsieur sueur et madame la présidente
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
donc nous assistons à l'opération
consistant à essayer de sauver quelques
morceaux de ruines au milieu d'un champ
mais mes chers collègues je m'exprime
librement comme chacun d'entre vous et
je pense que lorsque l'on assiste à
notre séance
et lorsque l'on assiste à nos débats
depuis lundi dernier
eh bien on a eu le temps de se faire
quelques idées eu de l'état de ce texte
mes chers collègues il est très
dommageable
il serait très dommageable de supprimer
cet article comme nous le demande le
gouvernement pourquoi parce que il ne
vous a pas échappé que le sénat a voté
contre l'article 35
l'article 35 bis 35 ter 35 quater et 35
points pièce c'est à dire mes chers
collègues que le sénat a décidé à une
large majorité d'ailleurs de retirer du
texte tout ce qui concerne les
compétences parce que il est apparu à
l'évidence que cela était très mal
rédigé créer beaucoup de contradictions
mettez les collectivités nos concitoyens
et les associations dans des situations
inextricables
bref ce n'était pas du tout au point et
il y avait de vives protestations donc
nous avons retiré tout ce qui concerne
les compétences
or le sénat a aussi majoritairement
décidé de réaffirmer la clause de
compétence générale pour l'ensemble des
collectivités
nous avons dit lors du vote et nous leur
disons que nous ne sommes pas du tout
fermé à ce que l'on puisse étudier la
question des compétences et des
prérogatives
d'ailleurs il a été décidé qu'il y
aurait une loi là dessus c'est bien ce
qu'a décidé le sénat mais en attendant
quelle sécurité
quelles garanties au milieu de cet océan
d'incertitudes et de doutes dont nous
font part quotidiennement les élus
locaux que de réaffirmer ce beau
principe de la compétence générale qui
est en fait le principe de la libre
administration des communes départements
régions
le principe de leur autonomie le
principe de leurs droits et de leurs
devoirs à l'initiative
enfin quelque chose qui tient debout et
qui tient d'autant plus debout que
l'article 35 et les autres n'existent
plus qu'il n'ya plus un mot sur les
compétences alors en retirant ses
phrases
et bien messieurs les ministres vous le
demander
mes chers collègues vous prenez vos
responsabilités évidemment c'est à dire
que les élus des trente six mille sept
cents communes de france des
départements et des régions verront
qu'après avoir magnifié la clause de
compétence générale dans son esprit et
sa philosophie dans une nuit du mois de
juillet après une demande de seconde
délibération après un débat sur les
votes de manière à ce que l'on n'essaie
de restaurer un petit morceau de ce qui
n'existe plus
eh bien vous aurez au forceps rétabli eu
la version antérieure
c'est à dire que pour le coup il sera
plus question de rien après tout plus
nous avançons plus ce texte s'établit
dans une sorte de néant à peine
entrecoupé par quelques articles qui ne
sont pas forcément tous inutile mais
enfin vous voyez bien que pour ceux
d'entre nous et j'en suis qui ont
assisté à pratiquement toutes les lois
de décentralisation et tous les débats
depuis 1982 vraiment jamais
et le dévouement de l'immense majorité
des 550 mille élus locaux qu'il y a dans
ce pays
non ils ne sont pas trop chers ils sont
d'un grand dévouement il apporte
beaucoup à la république
et si on les mettait en cause ce ne
serait pas bien et en même temps voilà
qu'aujourd'hui vous voulez créer des
conseils régionaux où il y aurait 200
300 personnes quelque chose de
pléthorique
comment expliquer que l'on veut faire
des économies et qu'on va multiplier par
trois le nombre de conseils régionaux je
voudrais dire le mot association car les
associations de ce pays sont très
inquiètes de ce texte
et l'on pourrait développer mais c'est
un vrai problème
il y à 1 million 250 mille associations
en france je voudrais dire le mot
chômage et le mot emplois j'ai
l'impression d'un décalage terrible en
quoi les dispositions de ce texte vont
nous permettre vous permettre à nos
collectivités d'être plus forte pour la
création d'emplois pour accueillir les
entreprises pour le développement et
pour la relance et pour lutter contre le
chômage
voilà un sujet qui serait intéressant
d'aborder voyez vous on a l'impression
d'être sur une autre planète
je voudrais dire le mot justice parce
que dans ce texte il n'y a rien sur ce
qui serait l'un des points essentiels du
troisième acte de la décentralisation à
savoir la péréquation
il ya trop d'injustice dans nos
collectivités dont souffrent des
communes défavorisées dans le monde
rural comme les communes de banlieue
y at il une seule mesure dans ce texte
qui changera la vie dans les communes de
banlieue ou dans les zones défavorisées
au parmi tous ces citoyens qui
voudraient eux davantage croire en la
politique et le dernier mot que je
voulais employés c'est le mot de
confiance je redis
parce que pour nous c'est important que
lorsque l'on voit la manière dont ce
texte a été débattu pendant dix jours
ici et quand on voit la séance
d'aujourd'hui je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit de nature à réconcilier nos
concitoyens avec la politique c'est une
grave question et il faudra un autre
souffle un autre idéal quelque chose qui
donne du sens pour la nouvelle étape de
la liberté locale de la décentralisation
et bien il y a encore beaucoup de choses
à faire et je crois que malheureusement
ce texte n'est absolument pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu feu président nicolas
bour ce président mes chers ministres
sur collègues dès le début de notre
discussion en général la du groupe a
indiqué que le texte transmis par
l'assemblée nationale ne nous convenait
absolument pas unanimement nous avons
décidé donc de défendre six propositions
importantes pour une réforme plus juste
et plus ambitieuse premièrement nous
avons proposé un mode de scrutin mixte
alliant un scrutin uninominal
majoritaire à deux tours et une dose de
proportionnelle correctives le
continuons à penser que c'était la
meilleure manière d'assurer la
représentation des territoires et des
populations tout en respectant mieux le
pluralisme
mais au terme de nos débats aucun mode
de scrutin n'est prévue dans ce texte
comme c'était d'ailleurs le cas en
première lecture nous faisons aussi le
constat qu'il n'y a pas au sénat de
majorité pour adopter un scrutin mixte
alors nous allons explorer d'autres
pistes mais chaque collègue cela doit
nous pousser à continuer à dialoguer et
à rechercher ensemble un mode de scrutin
qui garantisse le mieux possible le
respect des principes que nous avons
tous soutenus en première lecture
deuxièmement nous tenions à ce que la
répartition des conseillers territoriaux
respecte l'équité régionale
autrement dit nous tenions à ce que au
sein d'une région chaque conseiller
territorial représente un nombre
d'habitants mais pas seulement
représente aussi un territoire
sensiblement identique
là encore nous pensons que le vote qui
est intervenue ce soir ne signifie pas
que le débat soit clos
nous souhaitons que le dialogue se
poursuive et qu'ensemble nous
recherchions une répartition qui
concilie véritablement la représentation
démographique et la représentation
territoriale
troisièmement nous tenons fermement à ce
que les élections des conseillers
territoriaux favorise comme le demande
la constitution la parité quel que soit
le mode de scrutin qui sera finalement
retenu le dispositif d'incitation
financière graduée exigent que nous
avons proposé favorisera nous le pensons
l'égal accès des hommes et des femmes
aux mandats de conseiller territorial
quatrièmement nous souhaitions donner un
sens aux métropoles en réservant ce
nouveau statut à quelques grandes
agglomérations rayonnement international
le sénat a finalement retenu le seuil de
500 mille habitants en prévoyant que
certaines communautés urbaines pourront
également devenir des métropoles cette
évolution ne nous sommes pas assez
ambitieuse
on aurait pu parfaitement imaginer de
laisser le seuil suffisamment élevé de
retenir comme exception peut-être
strasbourg compte tenu de sa situation
tout à fait exceptionnelle au coeur de
l'europe
enfin l'élection des conseillers
communautaires place par fléchage et
l'achèvement de la carte intercommunale
constituent pour nous de vraies avancées
prévues par ce projet de loi cette
évolution doit aller de pair avec une
modernisation des règles qui encadrent
le cumul des mandats notre groupe a donc
proposé d'intégrer la liste des mandats
dont le cumul est encadrée dans les
fonctions exécutives au sein d un pc et
d'en exclure le mandat de conseiller
municipal
c'est une disposition pragmatique et
moderne dont nous saluons l'adoption
enfin nous avons proposé grain d'aile un
délai de 12 mois à compter de la
promulgation de ce projet de loi une loi
précise la répartition des
compétences des régions et des
départements ainsi que les règles
d'encadrement des cofinancements entre
les collectivités territoriales le nous
félicitons que cet enjeu essentiel pour
les élus locaux et les citoyens fassent
l'objet d'un meilleur traitement dans un
projet de loi distincts comme le
gouvernement le prévoyait initialement
sur l'ensemble de ce projet de loi
notre groupe a formulé des propositions
pour une réforme plus juste et plus
ambitieuse sur plusieurs fois nous avons
exprimé des positions différentes de
celles de nos collègues et partenaires
de la majorité mais les débats ont eu
lieu entre nous ces débats sont normaux
ils sont sains sur la manif est
seulement de la manifestation d'un
parlement actifs exigeant animé par la
recherche de l'intérêt général et par la
défense d'idées et de valeurs
je tiens à remercier nos partenaires de
l'ump qui ont permis aussi de laisser
passer les points que nous estimions
tout à fait fondamentaux et sans leur
soutien nous avons bien conscience que
pour beaucoup de ces points il n'aurait
pas été adopté ensemble nous avons
profondément modifié le texte transmis
par l'assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui notre groupe estime que nos
travaux ont permis de réelles avancées
dans ce texte
même si la réflexion et le dialogue
doivent se poursuivre sur des questions
importantes parce qu'elle estime que ces
avancées ne sont pas suffisants une
partie de notre groupe même s'il
reconnaît ses avances et s'abstiendra
parce qu'elle a le sentiment d'avoir été
entendu et d'avoir contribué à améliorer
cette réforme la majorité du groupe de
l'union centriste votera en faveur de
l'adoption de ce texte
ce vote favorable exprime notre volonté
de poursuivre le dialogue je le redis
nous espérons que cette volonté partagée
et que le travail du parlement se
poursuivra jusqu'à ce que le sénat
représentant pour moi constitutionnel
les collectivités territoriales et
l'assemblée nationale adopte un texte
commun à défaut d'accord entre les deux
assemblées
je ne pense pas que nous aurions réalisé
un excellent travail
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
par l'état monsieur mort et merci
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues quelques
mots en complément de ce que vient de
dire notre président de groupe pour vous
dire que on a eu l'occasion au cours de
cette discussion d'exprimer certains
regrets par rapport à ce texte et
surtout par rapport au fait qu'il
n'avait plus qu'il ne répondait plus à
la réforme ambitieuse qui nous avait été
annoncé et tout ce qu'on a pu exprimer
comme réserves portées sur ce point sur
ces points et je dois dire que quand je
lis ou j'entends qu'en fait tout nos
remarques nous réserve viendrait au fait
que tiendrait au fait que le sénat
serait conservateur et s'opposerait à
toute réforme
ça n'est en tout cas pas ce qui a pu
motiver nos remarques et nos réserves au
sein du groupe de l'union centriste
on a toujours été partisan d'une réforme
importante et et ambitieuse alors le
président à bout la très bien exprimé je
crois que on a obtenu au cours de cette
discussion et de ces débats un certain
nombre d'avancées qui sont tout à fait
significatives sur les compétences
on a obtenu effectivement qu'au lieu
d'avoir ce texte dont chacun
reconnaissait qu'il était un petit peu
fourre tout on est dans un délai d'un an
une loi qui règle la question des
compétences et des financements on n'a
pas réglé le problème en votant cet
amendement mais au moins on a fait en
sorte d'ouvrir un espace qui permettra
d'arriver à une solution plus
satisfaisante que ce qui nous était
proposé sur le mode de scrutin
nous avons également
fais en sorte que le mode de scrutin qui
nous venaient de l'assemblée nationale
et qui nous ne nous convenait pas soit
repoussée alors c'est vrai qu'on aurait
préféré arriver une solution ou un mode
de scrutin choisi par les sénateurs et
répondant naturellement aux attentes du
groupe centriste puisse être puisse être
adoptée moi ce que ce que j'ai observé
dans ce débat c'est que notamment les
groupes de l'opposition qui est
régulièrement expriment leur attachement
à la proportionnelle n'ont pas été
sensibles au scrutin mixte que nous
proposions et qui proposait pourtant une
dose de proportionnelle et sur les deux
points que je viens d'évoquer c'est à
dire les compétences et le mode de
scrutin
force est de constater que non seulement
c'est le groupe de l'union centriste qui
a obtenu des avancées mais force est
surtout de constater que l'honneur du
sénat a été restauré puisque nous avions
été les premiers à regretter que sur ces
points l'assemblée nationale soit saisi
en premier alors que l'assemblée
nationale alors que le rct au sénat de
lettres de d'autres points ont été ont
permis des avancées au cours de ce débat
la question du cumul a obtenu ce soir
une avance et ça n'est peut-être pas
encore un texte tout à fait parfait ce
n'est peut être pas le grand soir que
voudraient certains mais j'observe
qu'une fois de plus ce qu on avait déjà
observé en première lecture
nos collègues socialistes qui se
réclament d'une position très stricts
contrôles au cumul ont ce soir comme il
l'avait fait je le répète en première
lecture était plutôt hostile à toute
avancée en la matière puisque toutes
leurs interventions ont été pour rejeter
cette avancée qui a été finalement
obtenu ce soir sur la parité nous avons
également obtenu des avancées et donc
finalement nous avons un texte qu'il
faut bien le reconnaître est meilleure
et meilleurs que nos textes que nous
avions
lorsqu'il est arrivé ici et je l'avais
dit au président du groupe ump qui
parfois sembler un petit peu agacé de
nos positions
eh bien on a permis que le texte soit
meilleure et on a permis finalement
qu'ils soient sans doute dans quelques
instants
adoptée grâce à une grande partie des
voix du groupe de l'union centriste mais
mais
ce que je voudrais dire c'est
qu'effectivement la majorité du groupe
de l'union centriste va voter ce texte
mais que ça ne présage en rien du vote
qui sera le nôtre lorsque le texte
reviendra et notamment et notamment si
c'est un texte qui arrive de la
commission mixte paritaire
si ce que nous avons obtenu ce soir nous
on ne le retrouve pas dans le texte
c'est clair que le vote que nous faisons
que nous allons émettre ce soir sera
différent et puis je voudrais puisque le
temps mais vraiment content et je
voudrais m'élever ou en tout cas à
mettre en garde le gouvernement contre
l'idée selon laquelle ce texte pourrait
être votée en dernière lecture par
l'assemblée nationale
certes c'est un pouvoir constitutionnel
que détient l'assemblée nationale mais
je pense que ce serait un très mauvais
signe envoyé aux élus locaux et aux
collectivités locales que de dire qu'une
réforme qui les concerne a été votée
sans l'accord du sénat
ce serait perçu par tout le monde comme
le signe que cette réforme n'est pas
bonne et puis tout dernier point dans
les seize secondes qui me reste
moi j'aimerais j'aimerais que ces débats
et ces échanges que nous avons eus
ils nous servent que de leçons pour que
nous ayons un dialogue plus construit
plus fructueux avec nos partenaires de
l'ump et avec le gouvernement je crois
que nous aurions évité beaucoup de
tension beaucoup d'incidents de séance
si on avait eu des pratiques plus
régulière est meilleur en termes de
dialogue entre nos groupes et avec le
gouvernement voilà ce que je voulais
dire monsieur le président en m'excusant
avoir pris 15 secondes de plus merci la
parole est maintenant madame jacqueline
gourault
vous l'avez sûrement compris je vais
m'exprimer au nom de ceux qui vont ce
soir s'abstenir sur cette loi et je
dirais d'ailleurs que c'est conforme en
tout cas en ce qui me concerne au vote
que j'avais fait en première lecture où
je m'étais déjà abstenu
pourquoi sommes-nous arrivés à l'idée de
l'abstention la première chose je crois
c'est que et je les dis à cette tribune
plusieurs fois je nous avons fait je
crois un très bon travail sur
l'intercommunalité et que ce travail
très positif aurait mérité je les dis et
redis une loi distincte sur
l'intercommunalité comme c'était le cas
quand le même ministre avait proposé
avait on avait déjà commencé à
travailler sur ce texte
en tant que vice-présidente de la mmf je
ne peux que me satisfaire de cette
partie du texte sur l'intercommunalité
et je voudrais à ce moment aussi saluer
mes collègues messieurs belot et
krattinger avec lesquels j'ai beaucoup
travaillé et beaucoup d'autres sénateurs
pendant des mois et des mois monsieur le
président vous le savez pour faire ce
rapport et je crois qu'on mois sur
l'intercommunalité au moins sur ce
chapitre il y a beaucoup de choses qui
ont été respectées et je voulais donc
leur rendre hommage et rendre hommage à
tous les sénateurs de quelque parti que
ce soit qui on est quel groupe ce soit
qui ont travaillé avec nous
la deuxième raison c'est parce que là
les deux membres du groupe centriste en
particulier le président expliqué que
plusieurs éléments ont été acquis au
cours de cette lecture je ne reviendrai
pas sur tout je reviendrai simplement
sur deux points la loi compétences qui
sera je l'espère
respecter pour débattre sur les comptes
les compétences d'ailleurs j'aurais aimé
et je le répète commencer par cela avant
même que nous réformions la fiscalité
locale
je crois qu'il lui était intelligent de
commencer par débattre des compétences
avant de supprimer la tp et vous savez
dans quelle situation nous sommes
aujourd'hui sans clause de revoyure est
en attente de discussion dans la loi de
finances
alors bien sûr à ce moment de la
discussion je parle aussi du mode de
scrutin
j'ai entendu ce que mes collègues ont
dit moi je suis très attaché au mode de
scrutin mixte
je le dis et le redis et jeudi à gérard
longuet il est plus la vidéo
gérard il est là bas me n'entend pas
jeudi à gérard longuet sur le mode de
scrutin
il ya le fond et la forme quand même je
ne je n'oublie pas cette méthode qui a
été d'introduire en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale un amendement du
gouvernement alors que le texte
concernant le mode électoral était dans
une autre loi
et ça vraiment je trouve que ce ne sont
pas des méthodes et que ce n'est pas
respectée je dirais les parlementaires
et en particulier le sénat que d'avoir
fait ça donc comme disaient mes
collègues nous avons obtenu des choses
je voudrais dire aussi ici et remercier
ceux qui pour le mode de scrutin et je
dirais surtout les banques nous ont
accompagnés
l'ump a été remercié mais moi je
voudrais remercier aussi d'autres
collègues rdse socialiste et vous ramène
communistes qui ont ben oui c'est comme
ça qu'ils ont fait en sorte n'est ce pas
de supprimer le mode de scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours
bien troisièmement je m'abstiens aussi
parce que j'ai
troisièmement j'ai une idée aussi c'est
je pense que le texte va passer parce
que j'ai vu tous les cartons se préparer
et comme le texte va passer au moins j'y
vois un avantage n'est ce pas c'est
qu'il sera discutée à l'assemblée
nationale car si le texte n'était pas
passé au sénat
c'était le texte de l'assemblée
nationale qui était repris donc là au
fond c'est le texte issu du sénat qui
sera repris et donc nous verrons
vraiment si le président de la
république
si l'exécutif va va écouter le sénat
puisque là nous reprenons une loi avec
des choses qui ont disparu des choses
qui ont été ajoutés et nous verrons si
le sénat est respectée jeu même une
proposition à faire très très simple
très facile je pense que l'exécutif la
majorité serait comment dire ferait un
geste et messieurs les ministres
je vous demande vraiment d'être attentif
à ça si vous aviez l'élégance au fond de
l'europe de ne pas remettre le mode de
scrutin dans cette loi mais de faire en
sorte le mode de scrutin soit discutée
dans la loi 61
comme c'était prévu à l'origine ce
serait vraiment un geste fait en
direction du sénat je vous remercie
merci mes chers collègues
je suis saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public sur l'ensemble du texte
il est demandé par le groupe socialiste
je vais donc demander deux secrétaires
et aux huissiers de préparer la votation
madame joissains madame assassi après
une promotion de président
et
bien il va être procédé donc au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour remettront
secrétaire un bulletin blanc
ceux qui souhaitent voter contre a
bulletin bleu abstention à bulletin
rouge
le scrutin est ouvert
nouveauté c'est bon on ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos
j'invite mesdames les secrétaires a
procédé au dépouillement du scrutin
bien mes chers collègues avant de donner
les résultats du scrutin du numéro 2 159
jouvray votre nom à tous remercié la
commission des lois extrêmement
sollicités pour sur ce texte et sur bien
d'autres textes remercié le gouvernement
et remercia l'ensemble des sénateurs
mais l'ensemble de nos collaborateurs
qui ont été tout au long de ce texte
fortement sollicité les personnels du
sénat devait donc donner les résultats
du scrutin numéro 2 159 sur l'ensemble
du projet de loi de réforme des
collectivités territoriales nombre de
votants 340 nombre de suffrages exprimés
326 la majorité absolue des suffrages
établi dont 464 pour l'adoption 166
contre 160 le sénat a adopté l'ensemble
du projet de loi
c'était celle
réforme des collectivités territoriales
mais les sénateurs ont détricoté le
texte en rejetant les deux mesures
phares la répartition des compétences
entre les collectivités et le mode
d'élection l'assemblée nationale qui
aura le dernier mot a déclaré hier
nicolas sarkozy
le texte sera donc examiné en deuxième
lecture par l'assemblée
à la rentrée elle cet après midi à 15
heures vous pourrez suivre en direct sur
public sénat à l'audition de rémy
pfimlin rémy pfimlin c'est le candidat
choisi par nicolas sarkozy pour succéder
à patrick de carolis à la tête de france
télévisions est très bonne journée